Jimmy: The thing about
this film is that
the intention behind it was to
show a side of climbing that
I didn't think that mainstream
audience really got.
We embarked in 2008
on this climb
and started
shooting together
but one of the themes that we
talk about in the film is risk.
( sound of pitons
and ascenders )
So much of being a
climber and alpinist is
obviously risk assessment,
but you're also
struggling to move upwards.
It's a very kind of calculated
space you have to be in
and you have to
constantly balance
what your ego is telling you
and, your drive, and
the safety of the team.
Chai: Well, risk was this
I mean, it was constant dialogue
because what we were--
In this dream to have
this film kind of speak to
a more general audience,
we had to address this idea of
"are they bonkers or not"?,
like, "are they totally crazy"?
And the "crazy" question
always worked against that
because then people
would write them off
"they're just crazy".
And then another
side of this is that
the climbing community and
genre is quite understated.
Like, if you ask them
was that difficult
they're like,
"It was fine.
We almost died,
but it was fine."
You know, it's a very,
very understated culture
and there's like,
I've got some--
like, I'm allowed to make fun
of Jimmy for this a little bit
because I'm his wife and
his film-making partner
but it's just... I wanted--
It was important for me
to include the next clip
that we're going to show
because it was just
an interesting
and it wasn't included
originally and I...
it spoke to the understatement
of the culture, and...
how Jimmy was loathe to
put himself in the movie.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Xavier De La Rue.
( instrumental music )
Jeremy: The general mood
was pretty light
our objective for the
day had been reached.
Good vibes.
Our conversation
before dropping in was
go one at a time, make sure
everyone's in a safe spot.
Drop in!
Jimmy: So,
Jeremy made a couple of turns
cut up on the side
of this safe zone.
Called me in,
and I make a turn right next
to his turn, and then,
and then I feel it...
the whole slope... shift.
( sound of avalanche )
Jeremy:
I yell avalanche.
Just screaming,
"get out, get out, get out."
Jimmy: For a moment it looks
like slow motion
and the next moment everything
went to fast forward, and
it just... I got swept.
I'm airborne.
Totally weightless.
( sound of avalanche )
Jeremy:
And I lost sight of him.
That was the last I saw
Jimmy and the slide...
just kept going and going
and going and going.
Jimmy: I just got crushed under
an ocean of car-sized blocks.
Probably going 70-80 miles
an hour,
down 2,000 vertical feet.
And in my mind,
I heard this voice
having this conversation,
it was like
why I always wondered
how I was going to die
and now, now I know.
-( sound of avalanche )
-( trees snapping )
Jimmy: I was just expecting
to get torn to pieces
but after a while it
started to slow down
and this weird undercurrent
started pushing me up
through the snow, and
at the last moment I popped
out of the toe of this thing
buried up to my chest.
I was in that moment being like
"Oh, my god,
I'm in one piece"
like I coughed up this
huge chunk of snow
and I took this huge
breath and I was like
( sound of deep breath )
and I looked at my arms
and I was like, I mean
I couldn't even believe I'm
still connected to my body.
And then...
yeah, it was a lot.